is this [__] hairspray or semen semen
hi you're skinny people
oh no there's gonna be some angry people
at this video
that's right skinny people what do you
do chase me cuz I don't go run what uh
[__] would you think I'm gonna run [__]
I'm fat I'm gonna do [__] I'm gonna pop
my ass on the floor and you'll be like
aren't you gonna run I'm like no [__]
suck a dick
why the [__] would you even think about
chasing me you should understand innit
when the cops come after me I'm like you
know what dude
just get me check my butthole a keister
[__] it's gonna be like chasing a rock
[__] I ain't going nowhere no I don't
plan on running you know what you doing
[__] I'm slower than a [__] zombie i
watch like three episodes of The Walking
Dead and I loved it obviously a [__]
skinny with no [__] and by the way I
like doing why the [__] is it every time
I'm with a skinny person and it's cold
they [__] shake [__] bears
have insulation that's a survival tactic
maybe you should gets up every time
you're in a cold room you're wearing a
t-shirt and you're shivering and you're
wondering why random jump cut maybe you
should wear a sweater I like to wiggle
my and I'm not talking about skinny
people in third world countries where
they're starving to death
because they look fantastic insensitive
comment and if there are people out
there with a specific condition such as
anorexia or bulimia I'm just saying this
so I can take a little heat off my back
for being a dumb [__] I'm talking about
the 65% of North Americans that got
their health in check I'm talking about
the 65% of Americans that are yes skinny
you are so [__] skinny you are
affecting your own health
whenever you eat a tic-tac it looks like
you have a beats by dre pill in your
stomach you are so [__] skinny that
the only person on earth that can sag a
thong skinny bone is not a thing how
stupid do I look really [__] stupid
skinny shaking who can up that that's
[__] brilliant because that's not
real skinny people if I go out of my way
to insult you about you as a human being
and it helps you feel better about
yourself
what then I'm doing my job I'm glad that
I can go out of my [__] way
and you say it in the worst way possible
to affect you positively skinny people
you look very uncomfortable how do you
[__] walk in the buffet eat one thing
and say I got my money's worth that
doesn't [__] make sense when I walk
into a buffet people question whether
they're going to make a profit that's
called getting your money's worth
skinny people do you want to know why I
look so good being [__] around
em I'm out of shape yes I am a rowdy to
shake now suck a dick isn't it ironic
that a fat person is telling the any
person what to do with their life
randomly skinny people you are taking
your body for granted how do you feel
when you wake up and you put on an extra
small shirt and it's still baggy when I
fart you cute over like this that's
right who came up with this concept of
skinny shaming hashtag skinny shaming
skinny people tell me this how can you
buy jeans and not fill them out when you
buy your pair of pants it's also like
buying disappointment no I'm not gonna
fill this out my butt goes in there do
you want to be fat it's simple all you
have to do is eat moon you had one
serving you feel full guess what we call
that an appetizer you get a second plate
and then you'll feel like you're going
to burst
guess what take a [__] do you know how I
know why fat
I'm gonna do a video I sweat and so
here's an interesting story I went to
the airport I sit down at my [__]
seat and then there's this skinny [__]
right next to me number one then I sign
up for some extra arm room no [__] I
normal size though I have to let you
know that you're fat in your month she
looks at me like I'm invading her space
[__] aren't you skinny aren't you
always complaining that you're cold cop
into my [__] pit and then smother
yourself to you can't break no mo this
person was so [__] skinny and
irritated they had to push and roll my
fat over that should make you happy
don't you always want to work out it's
just like pushing those tires but this
[__] was coming over here complaining
that I smell like sausages [__] when
you go into a Denny's what do you expect
to smell you like that - smell [__]
especially sausages I'm not sometimes I
am so fat that I am that standing sweat
bag where crystal comes out my skin
which is why I still look really young
yeah I'm actually 52 by the way let's
throw it a random racist coming in here
big sassy black women that are fattest
fun or entertaining because they're fat
and black and I saw them in a Madea
movie why is it so hard for you to get
fat it's simple for me yesterday I
breathe in oxygen I gained 10 pounds you
know how you realize when you're fat
when you eat this amount of food but
your Dookie comes out this moment like
where did it go see I don't like giving
positive words of encouragement it
doesn't make sense because it's a
problem that you can fix easily right
because food is not an addiction you
have to realize something skinny people
if you want to be fat you have to put
the work in
like for me I am now addicted to food I
like the way food makes me feel and
guess what
getting skinny oh my god it's so [__]
easy
all I have to do is not eat right it
doesn't give me any emotional pain I
didn't grow up having people tell me
like less my human being because I'm
[__] fat because all the skinny
people got the best answers on earth yes
skinny people is time that you be fed so
I could share you the love of being fat
because fat people have never tried
losing weight yeah
never struggled with being [__] it
hate it for the way they look so fat
people the next time you see a skinny
person give them and McDouble give them
a [__] sandwich and punch them in
their chest because they're still before
being skinny skinny people you should
want to be fat because according to
other people they want to enjoy us as
human beings
only if we're skinny because if we're
fat comfor not even people is this come
in my hair because yes it is a lot of
you guys have suggested that I do this
video I'm doing this super [__] last
minute but if you can tell this is a
parody satire on the girl who made this
video so yeah a lot of the jokes are
insensitive much like the girls and kind
of doing a play on that I have to
preface this with this [__] because a
lot of people just might not get it you
know some people just dumb a [__] but
yeah I guess if you look at the message
as a whole she's saying that you should
cry gets care about yourself enough to
lose weight and be healthy but you get
in the way where you were demeaning
people and you're making fun of how they
are and who they are as a person rather
than the actual problem so you kind of
[__] dumb for that but you say you're
a comedian so I hopefully you do
understand how to package up jokes a
little better but anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed that video if you haven't I
don't know [__] you do something about
it even if you don't like it though I
subscribe because I need